a good friend comes uninvited
to begin as easy to persist as an art
everything is worth what the buyer will
pay
an old fox understands the trap
everything in its season
[Music]
proffered service stinks
[Music]
desperate times call for desperate
measures
[Music]
there is no little enemy
[Music]
you must meet roughness with roughness
out of sight out of mind
[Music]
adversity is the mother of wisdom
[Music]
take heed of enemies reconciled and of
meat twice boiled
[Music]
there is danger in delay
[Music]
don't make a mountain out of a molehill
[Music]
early ripe early rotten
[Music]
charity begins at home
whatever you do act wisely and consider
the end
it is not wise to open old wounds
[Music]
a good name is the best of all treasures
better late than never
precepts teach
examples move
better a fool with everyone else than a
wise man alone
do not judge others by your own
yardstick
better a sparrow in the hand than a dove
on the roof
zeal without knowledge is a runaway
horse
[Music]
a faint heart never won a fair lady
if life gives you lemons make lemonade
buy cheaply pay dearly
a good conscience needs no accuser
fortune favors the bold
the heart sees farther than the head
while the grass grows the steed starves
[Music]
paper is forbearing
[Music]
don't wash your dirty linen in public
a [ __ ] that grows too early gets its
neck twisted
a fish stinks from the head
the covetous man is good to none and
worse to himself
[Music]
envy is its own torturer
the wolf finds a reason for taking the
lamb
the best defense is a good offense
second thoughts are the best
beggars can't be choosers
a drowning man grasps at a straw
[Music]
eavesdroppers hear no good of themselves
[Music]
the straight path is the best one
[Music]
man proposes god disposes
every man thinks his own geese are swans
men are like fish the great ones devour
the small
[Music]
forget others faults remember your own
[Music]
self praise stinks
one certainty is better than 10
uncertainties
one today
is worth ten tomorrows
all's well that ends well
everyone should have a happy healthy
distrust
being alone is not good even in paradise
no one is as blind as the one who does
not want to see
[Music]
a disaster seldom comes alone
one swallow doesn't make summer
diffidence is the right eye of prudence
[Music]
poverty is the reward of idleness
what is learned in the cradle lasts
through the tomb
[Music]
joy shared joy doubled
sorrow shared sorrow halved
forced love and self-made colors do not
last
[Music]
great minds think alike
[Music]
birds of a feather flock together
[Music]
god lets us seek but not drown
[Music]
faith is half the battle
[Music]
one should honor the old
once you teach the young
a fool is ever
laughing the apple does not fall far
from the tree
different countries different customs
better to be alone
than in bad company
walking with a friend in the dark is
better than walking alone in the light
[Music]
one enemy is too many
a hundred friends aren't enough
[Music]
a nice wife and a back door oft make a
rich man poor
choose a wife by your ear rather than by
your eye
[Music]
[Music]
you